and Joe Biden has never and will never
give up on his son son Hunter and will
never treat him lesser then and so he is
a father first
you know when you see something like
this here's what you say you say okay
fine but like
are you really thinking everybody's dumb
they really do it's it's so so Trump is
no longer a father he's not a father so
Trump is not a man and Trump's kids
defending him is not the love of a son
for our father yeah it's not but it's
because it's true
in a sun relationship by the way she's
not wrong there is an element of it that
is a father and son but at this point of
the game The Father's probably sitting
there saying dude like can you stop
doing so much mess constantly the
favoritism you see here and the
hypocrisy is exposed and it's shown and
it's very easy it's not subtle it's in
your face this is when Alex Jones says
in your face this is in your face